hi I'm Erik Bosse and adventures in game
played a game that in the end ended up
being a real and game changer into this
work play game guys I'm stalling because
spoiler warning I am about to explain in
games complex plot and what it just did
to the MCU and I know you might not have
seen the movie yet but you know millions
of you did in the millions of you have
millions of questions I'm sure and in
this safe spoiler enable space we are
going to talk about it but if you
haven't seen the movie yet spoilers
ahead you know what better yet there
people haven't seen it yet or gone it's
just us now
and I am mentally exhausted because the
ventures endgame rewards the Marvel fans
like us who spent the past year
Wikipedian the quantum physics of
ant-man the wasp rereading dr. Selvig
sprays II blackboard and a poking pens
through folded napkins it worked yes the
Avengers use time travel to defeat
Thanos using the tricky physics of
quantum realm to zip back to past
moments with the Infinity stones and
steal him a true time heist but endgame
deliberately diverts from other famous
time-travel stories even mentioning them
by name in this movie Back to the Future
Terminator a hot tub time machine but
Banner says that those depictions of
time-travel are not how time travel
works here here going back in time
doesn't ripple effect change things
later in your timeline like those
butterfly effect awkwardness ripples
lorraine mcfly felt when her son aged
into someone she almost hooked up with
man this is the kind of time travel in
which actions are permanent and changes
cause new timelines to form banner
explains that killing Thanos says the
baby you know Rody's baby Hitler
proposal won't erase Thanos from their
timeline that change would just cause a
branch timeline where Thanos didn't
exist whereas back in their timeline
half of em would still be dead and Josh
Brolin's purple severed head would still
be rolling around on the floor in his
farmhouse this concept of time travel
causes a new branch timelines is
referred to as the many worlds theory or
the multiverse theory infinite parallel
realities were actually teased back in
the quantum physics lecture and ant-man
the wasp if you were paying attention
the object in question would be both in
and out of phase with multiple parallel
reality thank you Marvel Morpheus but
how does this play out an Avengers end
game well after the five-year aftermath
of Thanos his snap Scott Lang blasts
back
out of the quantum realm after a rat
crawls over the equipment of his quantum
tunnel van and impound
I assume that rats name is Mickey
because Disney is saving the universe
Scott was missing for five years but to
him it only felt like five hours because
down in the quantum realm he was within
a time vortex the concept hinted at by
Janet Van Dyne in the am and the wasp
post-credits scene and don't get sucked
into a time vortex we won't be able to
save you Scott accidentally slipped
forward in time and after joining cap
Natasha and Avengers HQ he theorizes
that they can reverse time as well they
take these crazy theories to stark who
is apparently already thought of all
this because of course he has he dropped
some big words the Planck scale
triggering the Deutsch proposition the
Planck scale refers to a subatomic
measurement it can measure space between
atoms or time because down there in a
subatomic level the physics of time and
space don't really function the same way
the Deutsch proposition is a reference
to the British physicist David Deutsch a
huge proponent of the many-worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics so
stark is essentially saying that the
subatomic physics of the quantum realm
allow for time to be manipulated across
multiple timelines Starke actually runs
a simulation of this on a projected
mobius strip mobius strip or a Mobius
loop is a geometric surface with only
one side and one boundary you can
actually make one by taking a paper
strip and giving it a half twist and
then joining the other sides oh this is
the napkin that I put a hole through it
doesn't really work first arc this is a
depiction of time travel with this
mobius strip representing space-time and
how it bends and how beans can loop back
around on it the other of interest
experiment with quantum realm time
travel with mixed results causing Scott
Lang himself to change ages wholly an
old man a baby
dart comes up with these devices that go
across their hands to keep the time
traveler unchanged as time around him or
her changes then the avengers split up
into teams and go back to different
points in history when they know where
the Infinity stones were they realized
that in 2012 the space stone the mind
stone and the time stone were all in New
York City at the same time so start cat
Scott and banner all return to the
Battle of New York rocket and fat Thor
go to Asgard to suck the reality stone
in ether form out of Jane Foster when
she was recovering in Thor the dark
world
rody and nebula go to
to get the power stone before quill
grabbed it at the beginning the first
Guardians and Hawkeye and Natasha go to
war Mir for the soul stone they wrestle
over who has to sacrifice themselves
Natasha wins it's sad but there are a
lot of hiccups with this time heist
stark loses the tesseract to Loki during
the Battle of New York who grabs it
portals away that forces cap and Stark
to quantum leap again back to 1970 when
stark knew the tesseract was in storage
in the shield warehouse of his father
Howard Stark but uh where does Loki go
this is why seeing this movie through
the lens of the multiverse theory is so
important when Banner meets with the
Ancient Ones she explains that their
timeline Medlin is causing branches to
break off of her main reality
potentially creating chaos there she
only gets in the time stone if he
promises to return all the stones to
where they found them so that they don't
disrupt the continuum too much cat
presumably returns the space stone to
the warehouse in 1970 but in 2012 Loki
has still stolen it and escaped that
branch remains Loki is still alive now
and we can assume that that separate
universe will be explored in Loki's
upcoming solo series on Disney Plus
there was another hiccup in this time
ice but first I'm actually gonna quantum
leap back to a past version of myself to
shout out a sponsor here we go thank you
to simply safe for sponsoring this video
simply safe is incredibly safe reliable
home security it's all monitored by
professionals 24/7 who will call you in
an emergency and call police help if
necessary it's all really easy and
intuitive to use it has really
thoughtful features with these small
sleep sensors you barely notice them
visually but they remind you if you've
left the door open
simply safe has fair and honest prices
no weird contracts or hidden fees and
these devices are equipped for
worst-case scenarios like they will
still work if you lose your power or
your Wi-Fi or the system is attacked for
me as this whole new rockstars operation
has grown we've been lucky to move into
more like legit office space but I know
in the past we've been in some kind of
dodgy spaces where I accidently trusted
to the nature a bit too much and left
the door open and then ended up losing
some headphones and some sunglasses but
you know what never again not gonna
happen here the setup was just so easy
from setting up the key
had the Homebase linking it all to our
Wi-Fi sticking the entry sensors and the
glass break sensors to the walls setting
up the water detection sensor by her
fridge and just finished it all made me
feel super secure and safe it's like I'm
an Avengers HQ Scott Lang is not getting
in I've never seen this guy before
please visit simply safecom slash new
rockstars to learn more okay back in
2019 another hiccup was nebula when she
was on Morag in 2014 the nebula of that
time still working for Thanos Scott
cross-wired Thanos the black order the
Gamora nebula of 2014 realized that the
Avengers of the future are screwing
around in the past so they sent 2014
nebula to pose as her doppelganger
return to the present day with the other
Avengers and as they snap everyone back
2014 nebula brings 2014 Thanos the Black
Order and Gamora Alta up there leading
to the craziest Marvel showdown I've
ever seen I can't wait to dig into it
another video no time here but the most
interesting mystery is how in-game
leaves and resets the Marvel timeline
cap takes the stones and we all near
which door took from 2013 Asgard quantum
leaps back again to return all of these
things to their rightful places in time
but it isn't return to the present day
he decides to stay in the past agent
into an old man and living a beautiful
life and we don't see caps return trip
but there are some timeline changes to
consider first of course after cap
returns the test director 1970 he jumps
again to the 1940s deciding to live out
his life with Peggy Carter the main
timeline has now been changed so that
the world saw a 20th century with Snead
Rogers not him vanishing and polar ice
during World War two and of course
there's a branch we talked about earlier
where Loki splits off into his own
timeline that I can't wait to see more
of and even though the main timeline was
still affected by Thanos the snap still
happened these people were still
traumatized for it even though they've
snapped back but there's an entirely
separate Marvel timeline in which
Stannis conquest ended in 2014 and he
never got close to gathering all the
stones Gamora also departed from that
timeline and now the Gamora missing the
present day is the version from the
first act of the guardians of galaxy in
2014 she doesn't have any memories with
quill or the other guardians over those
adventures and game ended with quill
looking for her on
starmap screen I assume the pursuit of
her will be explored in guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 but most interestingly
there's the mystery of what happened
when cap tried to return the soul stone
to Vermeer wood returning the soul stone
to red skull bring back Black Widow
would Red Skull say sorry no refunds
black widows solo movie is still in the
pipeline and even though it could be a
prequel set in the mid-2000s the
soulstone refund theory keeps the door
open for returning in other ways comment
down below with your favorite moment
from avengers endgame follow me on
instagram and twitter at evos and if you
live in the LA area check out my live
comedy show darkest timeline comedy
Friday May 3rd and every first Friday at
the Acme theatre in North Hollywood now
I'm going to make many other deep dives
into Avengers endgame but also just know
that I'm neck deep in Game of Thrones 2
so please be patient as I try to cover
both I love both but I will cover it all
whatever it takes